What joke? What joke am I telling? Am I a funny person? No, I just figured that I've got a joke. What do you call a boomerang that doesn't come back? I don't know, Connor. What do you call a boomerang that doesn't come back? A stick. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 21 recorded on april 3rd 2021 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we talk about galaxy brain programming languages and different programming paradigms. So, I watched, here's what we're going to talk about. We're going to play another game.
什么笑话？我讲什么笑话了？我是个幽默的人吗？不，我只是觉得我有个笑话。回旋镖如果不回来叫什么？我不知道，Connor。回旋镖如果不回来叫什么？叫木棍。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 21 期，录制于 2021 年 4 月 3 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将讨论“银河大脑”编程语言和不同的编程范式。所以，我看了，这就是我们要讨论的内容。我们要玩另一个游戏。
This will probably be a shorter episode, but I watched a talk, you might have seen this on Twitter a couple weeks ago, called Four Languages from 40 Years Ago, and it was given by Scott Wawashin, who's, I believe I pronounced his name correctly. If I didn't, I apologize. He's a prominent speaker, especially in the functional programming community and is known for his work in F-sharp. And he's a fantastic speaker. I'll link to The Power of Composition,
这期节目可能会短一些，但我看了一个演讲，你们几周前可能在 Twitter 上看到过，叫《四十年前的四种语言》，演讲者是 Scott Wawashin，我相信我读对了他的名字。如果没读对，我表示歉意。他是一位杰出的演讲者，尤其是在函数式编程社区，并以他在 F-sharp 方面的工作而闻名。他是一位出色的演讲者。我会附上《组合的力量》的链接，
which is a fantastic talk. He introduces the idea of railroad-oriented programming where you're basically, you play with functions as like Lego blocks. And, you know, it's fantastic. But anyways, if you're looking up the talk, that'll be cheating. Because we're... So the game that we're going to play, and I think that Scott made a big mistake
那是一个非常棒的演讲。他介绍了“铁路导向编程”的概念，基本上你就像玩乐高积木一样使用函数。总之，这太棒了。但无论如何，如果你去查那个演讲，那就作弊了。因为我们……我们要玩的游戏，我觉得 Scott 犯了一个大错，
because the best part of his talk is in the beginning, he has this little introduction, where he goes through sort of languages of importance from the 50s up until 1980, I believe. And he talks about, you know, oh, this language was important for this reason, this language was important for this reason. And every, you know, second or third language, he labeled as a galaxy brain language because it was, it contributed, you know, it was the first language to do X
因为他演讲中最精彩的部分在开头，他有一个简短的介绍，梳理了从 50 年代到 1980 年代（我相信是这样）的重要语言。他谈到，哦，这门语言因为这个原因很重要，那门语言因为那个原因很重要。每隔一两门语言，他就将其标记为“银河大脑”语言，因为它做出了贡献，或者它是第一门做某事的语言，
or it was important for some reason. And I think he should have called the talk galaxy brain programming languages, which is now I'm going to go give a talk and I have a blog article that I'm working on. And so what we're going to do, I do have a blog. Of and i have a blog article that i'm uh working on and so what we're gonna do of course i do have a blog of course i have a blog i honestly i made the i made the blog because i wanted to uh write a blog about how much i enjoyed the cpp cast episode when they brought on uh
或者它因为某种原因很重要。我觉得他应该把演讲命名为《银河大脑编程语言》，我现在要去发表一个演讲，我手头还有一篇正在写的博客文章。所以我们要做的，我确实有一个博客。而且我有一篇正在写的博客文章，所以我们要做的，当然我确实有一个博客，我当然有一个博客，老实说，我写这个博客是因为我想写一篇关于我有多喜欢 CppCast 那一期的评论，当时他们请来了……
jonathan turner um jason's cousin who has worked on like i don't know a bunch of different languages he's worked on rust he's worked on typescript he worked't know, a bunch of different languages. He's worked on Rust, he's worked on TypeScript, he worked at Microsoft for a while. And he just his story was just so fascinating as like a programming language enthusiast. And I was I was so excited about it. I was like, I need to go start a blog just so I can write a review of this episode. Anyways, but here's what we're going to do. There were eight galaxy brain languages that were mentioned in his history from the 1950s until 1980. And he sort of makes some remark, I think, like by 1980, we basically had discovered all the big ideas that exist in programming languages today.
Jonathan Turner，Jason 的表弟，他做过很多不同的语言，他做过 Rust，做过 TypeScript，他在微软工作过一段时间。作为一个编程语言爱好者，他的故事太迷人了。我当时太兴奋了，我想我必须开个博客，好让我能写一篇关于那一期的评论。总之，这就是我们要做的。在他的历史回顾中，从 1950 年代到 1980 年代，提到了八种“银河大脑”语言。他似乎发表了一些评论，我想，大概是到 1980 年，我们基本上已经发现了当今编程语言中存在的所有重大思想。
And everything that you see now is just a re-articulation of some idea that we already stumbled across. So there's nothing really new that's been invented since the 1980 mark. And we're going to play a game and see how many of these languages you can guess correctly. Oh, God. This is not good. Audience, this is not going to go well. I think you're going to do better than you think. And we'll keep track of how many how many wrong guesses you get
你现在看到的一切都只是我们已经偶然发现的某种思想的重新阐述。所以自 1980 年以来，并没有真正发明出什么新东西。我们要玩个游戏，看看你能猜对多少种语言。天哪。这可不妙。观众们，这不会顺利的。我觉得你会比你想象中表现得好。我们会记录你猜错了多少次。
i think you can easily get six of these uh six of eight and then i think you might struggle with the last two i'm gonna be happy if i get one all right you'll definitely get and that's the thing is if you saw those tweets um the four languages that scott talks about and focuses on so he gives a brief history at the beginning and then goes on to focus on four of these languages. They were four of the galaxy brain languages. So what do you want your first guess to be, Bryce? Oh, of galaxy brain languages? Yeah.
我觉得你很容易猜对其中的六个，六分之八，然后最后两个你可能会觉得困难。如果我能猜对一个我就很高兴了。好吧，你肯定能猜对，关键是如果你看了那些推文，Scott 谈论并重点关注的四种语言，他在开头做了简短的历史回顾，然后重点介绍了其中四种。它们就是那四种“银河大脑”语言。那么，Bryce，你想先猜哪一个？哦，关于“银河大脑”语言的？对。
I'm going to go with Lisp. Lisp is number two. And here's the hint that I'll give you, too. These were all introduced in chronological order. So Lisp is number two on that list. So you're one for one right now. Chronological order. Oh, wait, if it's number two, that means there's only one that's older than it. You are a smart cookie. Actually, and I'm totally wrong. So there's actually nine. I just I realized I put number two twice lisp lisp was originally lisp was like 1958 so that means that one of the other two like the one of the other two okay so there's only one you said there's only one that there's only one number before the number two and that's no no no but are we are these listed in in age
我选 Lisp。Lisp 是第二个。我给你个提示。这些都是按时间顺序排列的。所以 Lisp 在那个名单上排第二。所以你现在猜对了一个。按时间顺序。哦，等等，如果是第二个，那意味着只有一个比它更老。你真是个聪明人。其实，我完全错了。实际上有九个。我刚意识到我把“第二个”写了两次。Lisp 最初是在 1958 年左右，所以这意味着其中一个……等等，你说只有一个排在第二个前面，那不是……不，不，不，我们是按年龄排列的吗？
they're listening yes so so? Yeah, so the... So audience, that means that it's almost certainly got to be either COBOL or FORTRAN, and I got to decide which of those two I want to pick. Now, I personally think that COBOL is a more Galaxy-brained language because COBOL was the first language that was not developed by a company.
是的，它们是按年龄排列的。所以？是的，所以……观众们，这意味着它几乎肯定是 COBOL 或 FORTRAN，我得决定选哪一个。现在，我个人认为 COBOL 是一门更具“银河大脑”特征的语言，因为 COBOL 是第一门不是由单一公司开发的语言。
COBOL was like open source before open source was a thing. We're going to do a whole episode about COBOL. Like I know COBOL is not very modern today, but it was actually pretty, pretty, pretty modern back in the day. Like in the process by which it was developed was fairly novel. Yeah. So between COBOL and Fortran, it's got to be one of those two. I'm going to go with COBOL. I'm going to go with COBOL. That is incorrect. All right.
COBOL 在开源概念出现之前就像是开源的。我们要专门做一期关于 COBOL 的节目。我知道 COBOL 在今天看来不太现代，但在当时它其实相当、相当、相当现代。比如它的开发过程就相当新颖。是的。所以，在 COBOL 和 Fortran 之间，肯定是其中之一。我选 COBOL。我选 COBOL。那是错的。好吧。
And then I'm going to use another one of my guesses on FORTRAN. Hopefully that one will be correct. FORTRAN is correct. And so there's also a little sort of comment behind each of the languages. So LISP is 1959, according to Scott. I know 1958, it's sort of fuzzy which number gets chosen. Fortran is listed as 1957. The comments next to those languages
然后我要用我的另一个猜测机会选 FORTRAN。希望那个是对的。FORTRAN 是对的。每种语言后面都有一个小评论。根据 Scott 的说法，LISP 是 1959 年的。我知道是 1958 年，选哪个数字有点模糊。Fortran 被列为 1957 年。这些语言旁边的评论
is that Fortran was the first high-level language and that Lisp was the perfect language that you should read. That's not why I would pick Fortran. I'm, I'm surprised. I, like, I understand that reasoning, but there were a lot of other things that Fortran did that were fairly novel. Like the, the whole idea of like the, the symbolic computation of, of a programming language for math, there were a number of other ways in which Fortran was fairly novel. And it's interesting to me that that's the one that you'd,
是 Fortran 是第一门高级语言，而 Lisp 是你应该阅读的完美语言。这不是我选择 Fortran 的原因。我很惊讶，我理解那个理由，但 Fortran 还做了很多相当新颖的事情。比如整个编程语言用于数学的符号计算概念，Fortran 在其他许多方面也相当新颖。我很惊讶你选的是那个，
well, I guess in a vacuum, yeah, that's probably the most important aspect of Fortran was that it was the first of these high-level languages. Also, too, I thought the year associated with COBOL was 1960. So I'm actually surprised you guessed COBOL. I could be wrong about that, but... Yeah, you know what? I think you're...
嗯，我想在真空中，是的，Fortran 最重要的方面可能就是它是第一门高级语言。另外，我以为与 COBOL 相关的年份是 1960 年。所以我很惊讶你猜了 COBOL。我可能记错了，但是……是的，你知道吗？我觉得你……
Well, all of it's a little bit fuzzy. Yeah. I think of Lisp as being a little bit later there. But I think you're right. I think Lisp originally originated in like 1958. I think the years that Scott chooses are the years where there was the first implementation available. Because I know that a lot of these languages were being worked on um cobalt was designed in like the summer of 1995 it was cobalt 60 the first spec was published
嗯，这一切都有点模糊。是的。我觉得 Lisp 稍微晚一点。但我觉得你是对的。我觉得 Lisp 最初起源于 1958 年左右。我觉得 Scott 选择的年份是第一个可用实现出现的年份。因为我知道很多这些语言当时正在开发中……COBOL 是在 1995 年夏天设计的，那是 COBOL 60，第一份规范发布于……
in wait you just said you just said 1995 1959 the um the first and like when i say it was designed in the summer of 1959, I mean the entire language was designed over the summer of 1959, primarily led by a group of female programmers, which is another reason why COBOL was fairly innovative. And so Lisp, I think, did... I think the original ideas behind Lisp were like 1958, but the spec for it, I think, came out after the initial COBOL specs in 1959 and then the final one in 1960. Or not the final one, the final version of that first one in 1960 yep so i hope i hope all the listeners are playing along so bryce is two for three we've got the first two
等等，你刚才说 1995 年？是 1959 年。当我说它是在 1959 年夏天设计时，我的意思是整个语言是在 1959 年夏天设计的，主要由一群女性程序员领导，这也是 COBOL 相当创新的另一个原因。所以 Lisp，我想……我觉得 Lisp 最初的思想是在 1958 年，但它的规范，我想是在 1959 年最初的 COBOL 规范之后，然后在 1960 年发布了最终版。或者不是最终版，是 1960 年第一个版本的最终版。是的，所以我希望所有的听众都在参与。Bryce 现在是三猜两中，我们已经有了前两个
languages fortran in 1957 lisp in 1959 and that means there are seven languages sorry so i misspoke at the beginning there were nine galaxy brain languages in total so what do you want your next guest to be i guess i'm gonna have to go with c next that seems like a pretty a pretty safe one c is not a galaxy brain language this is fun. It's fun for you. I just imagine, too, that there's folks that are either exercising, they're out on a walk, or they're in their car, and they're playing along being like, why won't Bryce guess this one? Come on. How about... Say again, what's the criterion here? What is necessary for a language to be considered a galaxy brain language?
语言，1957 年的 Fortran 和 1959 年的 Lisp，这意味着还有七个语言。抱歉，我开头说错了，总共有九个“银河大脑”语言。那么你想猜下一个是什么？我想我接下来得选 C，这看起来是个相当安全的选择。C 不是“银河大脑”语言。这很有趣。这对你来说很有趣。我只是想象，还有些人可能在锻炼，在散步，或者在车里，他们也在跟着猜，心想：为什么 Bryce 不猜这个？来吧。再说一遍，这里的标准是什么？一门语言被认为是“银河大脑”语言需要什么条件？
I can only speculate based on the sort of the comments that Scott put next to the galaxy brain photos. But they're the languages that sort of were the first to do something or to introduce new paradigms or new things for the first time. I think Bryce is cheating now. I heard him clicking his mouse. It's going to Google. How about prologue? Ooh, and this is going to be so fun.
我只能根据 Scott 放在“银河大脑”照片旁边的评论来推测。但它们是那些率先做某事，或者第一次引入新范式或新事物的语言。我觉得 Bryce 现在在作弊。我听到他点击鼠标的声音了。他在用 Google。那 Prolog 呢？哦，这会很有趣。
So yes, prologue. Yeah. You are now three for five. So yes, Prologue. Yeah. You are now three for five, so you're batting above 50. That's 60%. See, the reason I said C was because it's been a transformative language, but this guy's been thinking about it from a – not from an impact in the industry, but from an impact in the field of programming languages.
所以是的，Prolog。是的。你现在是五猜三中。所以是的，Prolog。是的。你现在是五猜三中，胜率超过 50%。那是 60%。你看，我选 C 是因为它是变革性的语言，但这家伙考虑的不是它对行业的影响，而是它对编程语言领域的影响。
Yeah. So, yeah. So the, the comment next to prologue and so prologue is 1972 and it comes in at number six. It comes in at number six. Okay.
是的。所以，Prolog 旁边的评论，Prolog 是 1972 年的，排在第六位。它排在第六位。好的。
Hang on, hang on. I gotta, I gotta open up. Okay. So we got, we have, we have number one,
等等，等等。我得，我得打开看看。好的。所以我们有，我们有第一个，
we have Fortran. Number one, we have Fortran. Number two, we have Lisp. Is that right? Yeah. And then number, what, what did you, what number did you say it was? So number six is Prologue. And the years on all three of those respectively is 1957, 59, and 72. So we've got three languages in between 1959
我们有 Fortran。第一个，我们有 Fortran。第二个，我们有 Lisp。对吗？是的。然后第……你刚才说它是第几位？所以第六位是 Prolog。这三个的年份分别是 1957 年、1959 年和 1972 年。所以我们在 1959 年之间有三种语言，
and how many are there total? There's nine languages total. So you're missing number 3, 4, 5, 7, 8, and 9. Well, that narrows the problem down a good bit. And also, you're capped at 1980. What? This list.
总共有多少个？总共有九个语言。所以你还差第 3、4、5、7、8 和 9 个。好吧，这把问题缩小了很多。而且你的上限是 1980 年。什么？这个名单。
This list. I'm glad I didn't say JavaScript or Java, which were the next two that I was thinking about. Given that time range, and also given you, I'm going to have to say APL. I think I just have to. I'm insulted that it took you this long to guess APL. And I thank all of the listeners that have been yelling this. But it wasn't a talk that you gave. It was a talk that somebody else gave. All right.
这个名单。我很高兴我没说 JavaScript 或 Java，那是我接下来想到的两个。考虑到那个时间范围，也考虑到你，我不得不说 APL。我觉得我必须得说。你花了这么久才猜到 APL，我感到很受侮辱。我感谢所有一直在大喊这个答案的听众。但这不是你做的演讲。是别人做的演讲。好吧。
Where does APL go on this list? So APL, although many people think it's 1962, that was when the A Programming Language book that won Ken Iverson the Turing Award was published. The first implementation of APL didn't show up until 1966. And so the two comments also – so APL is number three. It's number three. Okay. We're getting somewhere.
APL 在这个名单上排第几？所以 APL，虽然很多人认为是 1962 年，那是 Ken Iverson 获得图灵奖的《A Programming Language》一书出版的时间。APL 的第一个实现直到 1966 年才出现。所以这两个评论也——所以 APL 是第三个。它是第三个。好的。我们有进展了。
We're getting somewhere i'm getting somewhere and the two the two comments next to prologue and prologue um it says introduced a new paradigm logic programming and apl is uh jokingly because he did say some nice things about it afterwards the first write-only language but he did he did also uh comment next to it that it uh it popularized notation as a tool of thought, which is the name of Ken Iverson's Turing Award paper in 1979. And then he mentioned that Ken also got the Turing Award for inventing the language. All right. All right. So that means you're four for six.
我们有进展了，我有进展了。Prolog 旁边的两个评论，Prolog……它说引入了一个新范式：逻辑编程。而 APL 是……开玩笑地，因为他之后确实说了它一些好话，它是第一门“只写”语言。但他确实也评论说它推广了“作为思维工具的符号”，这是 Ken Iverson 1979 年图灵奖论文的标题。然后他提到 Ken 也因为发明这门语言获得了图灵奖。好吧。好吧。这意味着你六猜四中。
Am I correct? Yeah, I got my D out for – hang on. It's safe to say that Bryce is on is on some wikipedia page i'm checking i am checking yours i mean i i i guess i'm gonna have to say um algol given that c's not on the list algol algol is not come on language this guy this guy so i i think in your defense um c and algol definitely got mentioned in the brief history of you know programming languages and he did remark that c uh and algol were two of the most influential languages. There was actually a language, this is not one of the nine, that he, the remark on the language was,
我猜对了吗？是的，我把我的 D 拿出来——等等。可以肯定地说，Bryce 正在看某个维基百科页面。我在查，我是在查你的。我的意思是，我猜我得说……Algol，既然 C 不在名单上。Algol，Algol 没……得了吧，这哥们……所以，我想为你辩护一下，C 和 Algol 确实在编程语言的简短历史中被提到了，他确实评论说 C 和 Algol 是最有影响力的两门语言。其实有一门语言，不是这九个之一，他评论说，
the most influential language never implemented. And I would, I have zero, I don't think you would get this. If you want to guess, you can. I think I had only heard of this once or twice in reading papers. How about Pascal? It was not Pascal. No, no, no. I'm asking if Pascal's on the list.
这是从未实现过的最有影响力的语言。我敢说，我觉得你猜不到。如果你想猜，你可以猜。我觉得我只在读论文时听说过一两次。Pascal 怎么样？不是 Pascal。不，不，不。我是在问 Pascal 是否在名单上。
Oh, that's one of your guesses. No. So you're now, I think, four for eight now. You're now at 50. This next guest is important. The language that I was going to say that was the most influential language that was never implemented is a language called ISWIM, I-S-W-I-M. I would not have gotten that. Audience, I would not have gotten that.
哦，那是你的猜测之一。不。所以你现在，我想是八猜四中。你现在是 50%。下一个猜测很重要。我说的那门从未实现过的最有影响力的语言叫 ISWIM。我肯定猜不到。观众们，我肯定猜不到。
And apparently it introduced, like like many of the functional programming concepts um but yeah it was never implemented all right so we got five five languages left two between 1966 and 1972 and three after 1972 i think you should definitely get three of these like i said there's sort of two that even i might not guess because one of them is sort of arguable whether it's a programming language oh sequel yes so i'll start i'll start giving hints so you're now uh sequel uh is 1974 and that's number eight number eight um wait 1974 and that's number eight hmm. Hmm, that's interesting. That's interesting indeed. Hang on.
显然它引入了，像许多函数式编程概念一样……但它从未被实现。好吧，所以我们还剩五个语言，两个在 1966 年到 1972 年之间，三个在 1972 年之后。我觉得你肯定能猜对其中三个，就像我说的，有两个甚至连我可能都猜不到，因为其中一个是否属于编程语言还有争议。哦，SQL。是的，所以我开始给提示了。所以你现在……SQL 是 1974 年的，那是第八个。第八个……等等，1974 年，那是第八个。嗯。嗯，这很有趣。这确实很有趣。等等。
So the remark of SQL is that it introduced a new paradigm, relational databases. You said it caps out at 80? Actually, at this point, you only have one language above 1974. I'll just tell you the year. It's 1976 is when this... So if there are any... See, that puts me in a tough situation because I have one that I want to guess, but I don't think it was...
所以 SQL 的评论是它引入了一个新范式：关系数据库。你说上限是 80 年？实际上，此时你只有一门语言是在 1974 年之后的。我直接告诉你年份。是 1976 年……所以如果有任何……看，这让我陷入了困境，因为我有一个想猜的，但我不觉得它是……
I don't think it was create... Hang on, hang on, hang on. I got to... There's a version of this language. The most well-known version of this language is, insert the name of the language, 80. The most well-known version of this language is, hmm, that's interesting. I think, actually. I might be mistaken because I think there's an 80 version.
我不觉得它是创建……等等，等等，等等。我得……这门语言有一个版本。这门语言最著名的版本是，插入语言名称，80。这门语言最著名的版本是，嗯，这很有趣。我想，实际上。我可能记错了，因为我觉得有一个 80 版本。
There's an 82 version. Oh, okay. It's small talk? That is correct. That is correct. 2 version um oh but okay it's small talk that is great i i i knew there were i knew that i knew that there was going to be um uh i'll tell you i'll tell you why there was going to be some sort of message passing or concurrency language um so small talk's not not surprising all right so well small small talk is so the remarks next to small talk sequel number eight and small talk's number nine okay all right the um the the comments next to small talk are that they it introduced the interactive uh ide uh the virtual machine garbage collection which um i, Lisp was the first language with GC,
有一个 82 版本。哦，好的。是 Smalltalk？那是对的。那是对的。2 版本……哦，但是好的，是 Smalltalk，那是对的。我知道会有……会有某种消息传递或并发语言……所以 Smalltalk 并不令人惊讶。好吧，所以 Smalltalk 是……Smalltalk 旁边的评论，SQL 是第八个，Smalltalk 是第九个。好的。好吧。Smalltalk 旁边的评论是它引入了交互式 IDE、虚拟机、垃圾回收，虽然 Lisp 是第一门有 GC 的语言，
but I think Smalltalk was the first language that really showed the power of the GC. Also, RealOO, which, like, that's also a hint, is that the comment is RealOO, because most people would remark that Smalltalk was the first, you know, purely OO language. But there is another language on this list that some people say was the actual first object-oriented language. See, that makes me want to... It makes me want to... You're at six for ten right now, so you just you're still batting all right i got i gotta guess at this point then uh i thought it was pronounced ada but um i uh it is not ada is
但我认为 Smalltalk 是第一门真正展示了 GC 威力的语言。还有，RealOO，这也是个提示，评论是 RealOO，因为大多数人会说 Smalltalk 是第一门纯面向对象语言。但名单上还有另一门语言，有些人说是真正的第一门面向对象语言。看，这让我想要……这让我想要……你现在是十猜六中，所以你表现还可以。好吧，我得猜了。嗯，我以为它读作 Ada，但……它不在名单上，而且我也不觉得 Ada……
not on the list and i also don't think ada i thought ada was created in like the late 80s no it's like uh 78 79 but I thought it could have been 76. Well, so that's the, you're not using your information correctly because you know that there's only three languages left. Two of them are between 66 and 72. All right, how about ML? ML is on the list, ladies and gentlemen. That's the 1973 one, right? Because that's around the right time time for ml correct yes all right so there's there's two other ones between 1966 and 1972 ml for those uh that
我以为 Ada 是在 80 年代末创建的。不，它是 78、79 年左右，但我以为可能是 76 年。好吧，所以你没有正确使用你的信息，因为你知道只剩下三门语言了。其中两个在 66 年到 72 年之间。好吧，ML 怎么样？ML 在名单上，女士们先生们。那是 1973 年的，对吧？因为那是 ML 的正确时间。正确，是的。好吧，所以还有两个在 1966 年到 1972 年之间。ML，对于那些……
don't know is stands for meta language and the remark next to that one is it introduced a new paradigm of functional programming which uh i'll i'll say something once we finish all right give me some hints for these other two so it's uh funnily enough ml and um sequel were the two languages that i thought you might not get so the two that are remaining i thought you would have an easier time getting so the one that i'm really surprised you haven't guessed one of these you definitely know the language because it is one of the ancestor languages of c++ in fact you can argue that the ancestor languages of c++ no you you could argue that c plus this language equals c++ c plus this language. So what does C plus plus minus C give you? Yeah. Really?
不知道的人，代表“元语言”（Meta Language），旁边的评论是它引入了函数式编程的新范式，我会在我们结束时说点什么。好吧，给我这两个的提示。所以，有趣的是，ML 和 SQL 是我以为你可能猜不到的两门语言。剩下的两个，我以为你会更容易猜到。其中一个你肯定知道，因为它是 C++ 的祖先语言之一。事实上，你可以争辩说 C++ 的祖先语言……不，你可以争辩说 C 加上这门语言等于 C++。C 加上这门语言。所以 C++ 减去 C 得到什么？是的。真的吗？
B? D? No, B, I said. B. Oh, B, B. I was like, D definitely didn't come out until, like, the 2000s. B is not correct. Really?
B？D？不，我说的是 B。哦，B，B。我当时想，D 肯定要到 2000 年代才出来。B 是不对的。真的吗？
Okay. All right. What did B do? B introduced structs? How about Simula? Because isn't that object-oriented? It is Simula. Yes.
好吧。好吧。B 做了什么？B 引入了结构体（structs）？Simula 怎么样？因为它不是面向对象的吗？是 Simula。是的。
Simula 67 was the first language with classes and inheritance. Was that four or five? That was number four. So was that the one you were just talking about? The one that's C++ minus the C? Yes. And this is also the one that a lot of folks argue is actually the first OO. Like a lot of folks say that the first object-oriented, purely object-oriented language was Smalltalk. And like they're the one that popularized object-oriented programming.
Simula 67 是第一门有类和继承的语言。那是第四个还是第五个？那是第四个。所以那是你刚才说的那个吗？那个 C++ 减去 C 的那个？是的。这也是很多人争论是真正的第一门 OO 语言的那个。很多人说第一门纯面向对象语言是 Smalltalk，而且他们是推广面向对象编程的那一个。
But then there's some folks that say, well, really, Simulus 67 was the first true OO language. I'm just impressed that I got Prolog. All right, so tell me, give me something about this last one. So, yeah, this last one is, I believe it was invented by Chuck Moore. Don't Google that. I'll Google it for you just to make sure that
但也有人说，好吧，其实 Simula 67 才是第一门真正的 OO 语言。我只是对猜到 Prolog 感到印象深刻。好吧，告诉我，给我关于最后一个的提示。所以，是的，这最后一个，我相信是 Chuck Moore 发明的。别去 Google。我会帮你 Google 一下，以确保
I've got that correct. And it's known as Yes. Chuck Moore is a computer American computer engineer and programmer best known for inventing this programming language. That does not help me.
我没记错。它被称为……是的。Chuck Moore 是一位美国计算机工程师和程序员，最出名的是发明了这门编程语言。这对我没帮助。
It doesn't help you, but it's widely known as one of the easiest, if not the easiest, programming languages to implement. As like taking a first stab at implementing a language to get your toes wet. Oh, well, I mean, I know what... Wait, no, that wouldn't work for the timeline, though. Oh, and here's actually a great clue. I'm not sure if this will help at all. It has five letters in its name,
它对你没帮助，但它被广泛认为是实现起来最容易的编程语言之一，如果不是最容易的话。就像作为实现语言的第一次尝试，让你练练手。哦，好吧，我的意思是，我知道……等等，不，那不符合时间线。哦，这里其实有个很好的线索。我不确定这是否有帮助。它的名字有五个字母，
and it actually was supposed to be six letters. So, like, the word that they chose was six letters, but due to some limitation with, like, word length on some system, they had to remove one of the letters. It's five letters in the name. Which, like, it was, it's easy to implement. It's between 67 and... 72. All right, I'll give one more hint. It's known as...
而且它其实本应该是六个字母。所以，他们选择的词是六个字母，但由于某些系统对字长的限制，他们不得不去掉一个字母。名字里有五个字母。它很容易实现。它在 67 年到……72 年之间。好吧，我再给一个提示。它被称为……
The remark next to it is it's the first use of concatenative programming. So it's a... And if you're not familiar with that, that means it's a stack-based language. A stack-based language. That was, that's five letters in between 67 and 72. I mean, if you're familiar with stack-based languages,
旁边的评论是它是连接式编程（concatenative programming）的首次使用。所以它是一个……如果你不熟悉这个，这意味着它是一门基于栈的语言。一门基于栈的语言。那是五个字母，在 67 年到 72 年之间。我的意思是，如果你熟悉基于栈的语言，
this is the most famous one of all. So like other stack-based languages that are less well-known are like joy factor um and they're all basically derivatives of this language hang on i got so like when you talk i got an idea i don't actually know anything about this language is it fourth it is fourth look at that you're nine for 15 that's uh that what is that? That's 3 over 5. That's 60%. That's pretty good. Oh, boy.
这是其中最著名的一门。所以其他不太出名的基于栈的语言，比如 Joy、Factor……它们基本上都是这门语言的衍生品。等等，我有个主意。我其实对这门语言一无所知。是 Forth 吗？是 Forth。看，你 15 猜 9 中，那是……那是什么？那是 5 分之 3。那是 60%。那相当不错。天哪。
I do not like your games, Connor. I don't like them at all. So, yeah, 4th dropped the U. I can't remember why they wanted to call it 4th. I think it was, like, the 4th implementation of something. There's some story behind it because like that's not a name where it's like obvious that uh uh like there's not it's not a name where there's like an obvious character that you could drop but like nobody still uses fourth right that's not true um uh it's too bad ben dean's not here, because Ben Dean knows more stuff about this language.
我不喜欢你的游戏，Connor。我一点也不喜欢。所以，是的，Forth 去掉了 U。我不记得他们为什么想叫它 4th。我想，它可能是某种东西的第四个实现。这背后有个故事，因为那不是一个名字，让你觉得……比如，那不是一个名字，让你觉得有一个明显的字符可以去掉，但现在没人用 Forth 了，对吧？那不是真的……太可惜 Ben Dean 不在这里，因为 Ben Dean 对这门语言了解更多。
And it's used on a lot of OS implementations. I'm not sure if they're OS implementations, but it's a super good language for where you have constrained resources and you need a really small memory footprint, because it's such a simple language to implement. It has like, it's very small footprint and actually is very high performance because it's such a simple language. And it's a really interesting language. Like it basically has a bunch of verbs,
它被用于很多操作系统实现中。我不确定它们是否是操作系统实现，但对于资源受限且需要极小内存占用的地方，它是一门超级好的语言，因为它是一门非常简单的语言。它占用空间非常小，而且实际上性能很高，因为它是一门非常简单的语言。它是一门非常有趣的语言。它基本上有一堆动词，
not verbs, but functions that are basically like ROT for rotate, DUP for duplicate, REV for reverse. And basically you have to build up an expression that does some simple calculation. And a lot of them make use of something I've talked about with respect to APL called combinators, where you need to sort of manipulate the order of the arguments in order to do something, because you're always evaluating the thing that's at the top of the stack. So it's a very, very interesting paradigm. I'm too obsessed with APL right now to go and learn it and explore it. But once I get over that obsession, it's definitely on my list. And yeah, so the reason that I think this is interesting is that
不是动词，而是函数，基本上像 ROT（旋转）、DUP（复制）、REV（反转）。基本上你必须构建一个表达式来做一些简单的计算。其中很多利用了我之前在 APL 中提到的组合子（combinators），你需要操纵参数的顺序来做某事，因为你总是评估栈顶的东西。所以这是一个非常、非常有趣的范式。我现在太沉迷于 APL 了，没法去学习和探索它。但一旦我克服了这种痴迷，它绝对在我的名单上。所以，我认为这很有趣的原因是，
the blog that I'm working on was titled for a long time, The Eight Programming Language Families. And it's based on a former blog by Ben Dean called Six Programming Languages Worth Knowing, where he, I actually don't even have the full list of six. Actually, I can just click on this link and it will bring me to the article. full list of six languages are algal the algal family so c and any of its descendants fourth lisp haskell smalltalk and erlang and then ben also has a tweet where he mentions a list of seven languages i believe and apl is on that list and so i sort of i combined those both ben's tweet and his blog, and then you end up with eight languages. ALGOL, FORTH, LISP, HASKEL, SMALLTALK, EARLANG, PROLOG, and APL.
我正在写的博客标题很长一段时间都是《八个编程语言家族》。它基于 Ben Dean 以前的一篇博客《六门值得了解的编程语言》，我甚至没有那六门的完整列表。其实，我可以点击这个链接，它会带我到那篇文章。六门语言的完整列表是 Algol，Algol 家族，所以 C 及其任何后代，Forth，Lisp，Haskell，Smalltalk 和 Erlang。然后 Ben 还有一条推文，提到了七门语言，我相信 APL 就在那个名单上。所以我结合了 Ben 的推文和他的博客，最后得到了八门语言：ALGOL、FORTH、LISP、HASKELL、SMALLTALK、ERLANG、PROLOG 和 APL。
And I thought it was super interesting that the overlap with the Galaxy Brain languages in Scott's talk is almost 100%. So Scott adds Simula67. He adds FORTRAN. He doesn't include Erlang. And then he adds SQL. And then I would argue that like ML versus Haskell, those are just two different languages that are both extremely functional. And the point here being that I watched a YouTube video by some, you know, computer science educator that was saying, you know, programming languages don't matter.
我觉得 Scott 演讲中的“银河大脑”语言与此重合度几乎是 100%，这非常有趣。所以 Scott 增加了 Simula 67。他增加了 FORTRAN。他没有包括 Erlang。然后他增加了 SQL。然后我会争辩说，ML 和 Haskell 只是两门极其函数式的不同语言。这里的重点是，我看了某个计算机科学教育家的 YouTube 视频，他说，编程语言并不重要。
I have the exact quote here. I have courses on C, C++, Java, Ruby, PHP, Dart, JavaScript, all these different languages. Teaching these languages, teaching these different languages, I'm literally doing the same thing. And if you like listen to that list of languages, C, C++, Python, Java, Ruby, PHP, Dart, JavaScript, they're all from the same category. They're all basically like C or algol derivatives. You could argue that Ruby is a small talk derivative because basically Ruby is small talk with just nicer syntax. But the point being is that like someone remarking that like, oh, like learning C or C++ or Python or Java, like there's no difference.
我这里有确切的引文。我有关于 C、C++、Java、Ruby、PHP、Dart、JavaScript 的课程，所有这些不同的语言。教授这些语言，教授这些不同的语言，我实际上在做同样的事情。如果你听听那个语言列表，C、C++、Python、Java、Ruby、PHP、Dart、JavaScript，它们都属于同一类别。它们基本上都是 C 或 Algol 的衍生品。你可以争辩说 Ruby 是 Smalltalk 的衍生品，因为 Ruby 基本上就是语法更友好的 Smalltalk。但重点是，有人评论说，哦，学习 C 或 C++ 或 Python 或 Java，没什么区别。
Well, it's like, well, yeah, that's because they're all in the same category. If you're going to go and learn a new language, don't choose a language from the same family. Like it's the equivalent of if you know French and then you go and learn Spanish. Well, it's not super different, whereas if you know French and then you go and learn Korean, that's an entirely different language, and it's going to change the way you have to think about things. And the point here, the point about the blog is just, if you're exploring languages, choose languages from different paradigms and different families.
嗯，那是因为它们都在同一个类别里。如果你要学习一门新语言，不要选择同一个家族的语言。这就像如果你懂法语，然后去学西班牙语。嗯，差别不大，而如果你懂法语，然后去学韩语，那是一门完全不同的语言，它会改变你思考问题的方式。关于博客的重点就是，如果你在探索语言，选择来自不同范式和不同家族的语言。
So the list in total was fortran 1957 list 1959 apl 1966 simula 1967 fourth 1970 prologue 1972 ml 1973 sequel 1974 in small talk 1980 um all right all right so if we look 1976 technically for small talk but yeah okay if we look past um uh if we look past 1980 what other languages would you add to this list i already have a couple um i would probably add erlang because it was one of the first languages to be designed from the ground up with concurrency and distributed computing in mind. And it was introduced in the 80s. So it sort of, it preceded the multi-core revolution. I think I would also say both Java and JavaScript for somewhat different reasons. well okay there were arguably languages before java that introduced the idea of an abstract machine um and have run anywhere but um i still would argue that java um uh introduced it in sort
所以总名单是：Fortran 1957，Lisp 1959，APL 1966，Simula 1967，Forth 1970，Prolog 1972，ML 1973，SQL 1974，Smalltalk 1980。好吧，好吧，如果我们看 1980 年之后，你还会把什么语言加到这个名单上？我已经有几个了……我可能会加上 Erlang，因为它是第一门从头开始设计时就考虑到并发和分布式计算的语言。它是在 80 年代引入的。所以它先于多核革命。我想我也会说 Java 和 JavaScript，原因略有不同。嗯，好吧，在 Java 之前可以说有引入抽象机概念的语言……并且可以在任何地方运行，但我仍然会争辩说 Java 以一种新颖的方式引入了它，然后是 JavaScript，因为它是第一门以 Web 为中心的语言……以 Web 为中心的语言。它是一门从头开始设计用于在浏览器中运行的语言。虽然现在它在许多其他地方运行。那么你呢？你认为哪些语言会是现代时代的“银河大脑”语言？或者你认为应该在名单上但不在的旧时代语言？
of a novel way and then javascript because it was the first um web centric um uh language um web-centric language. It was a language which was, you know, originally designed from the ground up to run, you know, in your browser. Although now it runs in many other places. So what about you? What languages do you think would be galaxy brain languages
是的，我同意 Erlang。我不同意 Java，因为我觉得 Java 里的一切都在 Smalltalk 里，然后 Sun 只是往 Java 里砸了数百万美元，这就是它最终胜出的原因。不是因为技术上……它不是一门技术上更优越的语言。那是一个营销问题。
from the more modern era? Or ones from the older era that you think should have been on his list but weren't yeah i i agree with erlang um i disagree with java because i think everything in java was in smalltalk um and then uh sun just went and threw millions of dollars at java and that's why it ultimately won it wasn't because of technically um like it wasn't a technically superior language. It was a marketing thing.
Smalltalk 出自 Xerox，Xerox 以不懂得如何营销他们的东西而闻名。Apple 来了，只是……我不应该说剽窃。真实的故事是，他们实际上是合作的，他们分享了想法。Xerox 有这么多好点子，
And Smalltalk came out of Xerox, which is like famous for not knowing how to market their stuff. Apple came along and just like ripped off all, I shouldn't say ripped off. The true story is that really they were collaborative and they shared ideas. And Xerox had so many good ideas,
即使他们是好的营销人员，他们也无法把它们全部卖出去。JavaScript 我也会部分不同意。我的意思是，JavaScript 被称为浏览器里的 Lisp，它最初的设计完全就是那样，它被称为 LiveScript。HTML 怎么样？我的意思是，我会争辩说 HTML 不是一门语言，我不想挑起那场战争，但我把你困住了。我只是对我们所有的 HTML 程序员说，那是 Connor 说的，不是我。我的意思是，我同意浏览器里有一些新颖的东西，但这只是一个新的领域，某种意义上的“Lisp”。然后我想 Sun，或者我觉得故事是 Sun
even if they were good marketers, they wouldn't have been able to sell them all um javascript i would also quasi disagree with i mean javascript is known as like just lisp in the browser it was originally um designed exactly like that and it was called live how about html and um i mean i would argue html is not a language and i don't i don't want to start that war but i i trapped you i just like all to all to all of our listeners who are html programmers it's connor said that not me um um i mean like i i i agree that like there's something novel about the browser but like it's just a new sort of it's just a new domain that sort of a quote-unquote Lisp. And then I think Sun or I think the story was that it was Sun
他们在创建 LiveScript，它看起来太像 Lisp 了。所以他们说，我们希望它看起来像 Java。所以他们重写了它，保留了 Lisp 的核心本质，然后让它看起来更像 Java，然后重新命名为 JavaScript。所以我同意 Erlang。我不会加 Java 或 JavaScript。我想我实际上会加 Rust。
that they were creating LiveScript and it looked too much like Lisp. And so they said, we want it to look like Java. And so they rewrote it, kept the sort of Lisp core nature to it, and then made it look more like Java than rebranded it as JavaScript. So I agree with Erlang. I wouldn't add Java or JavaScript. I think I would actually add Rust.
你会加 Rust。我说过基本上自 1980 年代以来没有发明什么新东西。但 Rust，你可以争辩说它的内存安全性实际上是新颖的。它是第一门带有那种安全保证的系统级语言，我想有些人争辩说它实际上是第一个实现的。这又回到了我关于 Ada 不在名单上的问题。Ada 怎么会不在名单上？一门引入了“契约式设计”（design by contract）作为语言特性的语言。
You'd add Rust. I said that basically nothing new has been invented since the 1980s. But Rust, you could argue with their um memory safety um is actually novel it's the first language uh to have like it's the first systems level language that comes with that kind of safety guarantee and i think some people argue that it was actually first implemented. This gets back to my issue with Ada not being on this list. Like, how is Ada not on this list? A language that introduced the notion of design by contract as a language feature.
是的。我坦率地说，我很震惊它不在名单上。我不知道关于……它是怎么读的？我不知道。好吧，你说 Ada，我说 Ada，我们其中一个……它是一门语言，我想它是在 77 年左右首次引入的，它有……现在它有并发，我不知道并发是什么时候加进去的，但它是从头开始设计的语言，供国防部使用，用于关键的国防部系统，它从头开始构建，是一门提供关于确定性等非常强保证的语言，你可以让你的前置条件和后置条件非常清晰，最重要的是，你可以形式化验证程序的正确性，这可是件大事，而且……
Like, yeah. I'm frankly shocked that it's not on the list i don't know uh anything about uh is it i i pronounce it i do not know all right well you say ada i'll say ada and one of us it was a language that that like i think it was first introduced in like 77 um it had uh well now it has concurrence i don't know when concurrency was added to it but like it was the language designed from the ground up um for use by the dod um uh for like critical dod systems and it was sort of built from the ground up to be a language that provided very strong guarantees regarding determinism, et cetera, where you could make your preconditions and your prec conditions very clear and more most importantly where you could formally verify the correctness of a program um which is like a big deal and like
是的，我只是很震惊它不在名单上。我很震惊它不在名单上，而且我觉得如果 Rust 属于这个名单，Ada 或者 Ada，无论你怎么读，都属于这个名单。好吧，有几件事我要说。第一，如果你要争辩说 Rust 应该在名单上，我想有些人比我更了解这一点，他们实际上说 Clean 才是第一门尝试那个想法的语言。然后 Rust 从 Clean 那里借用了这个语言。
yeah i'm just i'm shocked that it's not on the list i'm shocked that it's not on the list and i think definitely if russ belongs on the list at ada or ada however you want to pronounce it belongs on the list uh well so couple of things I was going to say. One, you could, if you're going to argue that Rust should be on the list, I think there's some folks that know more than I do about this that actually say that Clean was actually the language that first experimented with that idea. And then Rust borrowed the language from Clean.
是的，我只是……我很震惊它竟然不在名单上，我很震惊它不在名单上。而且我认为如果 Rust 应该在名单上，那么 Ada——或者无论你怎么发音——肯定也应该在名单上。嗯，有几件事我想说。第一，如果你要争论 Rust 应该在名单上，我想有些人比我更了解这一点，他们实际上说 Clean 才是第一个尝试这个想法的语言，然后 Rust 从 Clean 那里借鉴了这种语言。
Ada, I don't, yeah, like I said, I don't know enough about. Do you know if ada was invented before eiffel yeah i thought it was another one that i was thinking about um uh eiffel for those of you that don't know is the language that i associate with uh contracts and that typically contracts yeah for those of you that are not familiar it's like preconditions post conditions and like making sure that that's uh definitely um ada definitely um precedes eiffel predates if that's the case then yeah uh arguably ada should be on the list so yeah erlang like i said though i i wouldn't say for sure rust. I just, that is quasi-novel. And then potentially I would add a language like Agda or Idris to the list because that's
Ada，我，是的，就像我说的，我对它了解不够。你知道Ada是在Eiffel之前发明的吗？是的，我以为那是我想到的另一个，嗯，Eiffel，对于那些不知道的人来说，是我与契约联系在一起的语言，通常是契约，是的，对于那些不熟悉的人来说，它就像前置条件、后置条件，确保这一点，嗯，Ada绝对是在Eiffel之前，如果真是这样的话，那么是的，可以说Ada应该在名单上，所以是的，Erlang，就像我说的，我不敢肯定Rust。我只是觉得那是准新颖的。然后我可能会在名单中加入像Agda或Idris这样的语言，因为那是
like dependently typed languages that are currently being, it's the equivalent of what Haskell was in the early 90s. They're just sort of academic experimental things right now. But, you know, 20 years from now or, you know, like, qualify. um essentially you write like some uh if i recall the idea correctly you write some like constraints um uh or you you partially write the program and then like ml or something figures out the rest of what you wanted oh is it called um angelic because it's uh what do they call it um it's like it's holy because you you basically create type holes and then the compiler right i think that's right yeah
像依赖类型语言，目前正在被使用，这相当于90年代初的Haskell。它们现在只是一些学术性的实验性东西。但是，你知道，20年后，或者，你知道，限定一下。嗯，本质上你写一些，如果我没记错的话，你写一些约束，或者你部分地编写程序，然后像ML之类的东西算出你想要的其他部分，哦，它叫天使式编程吗？因为它是，他们称之为什么，嗯，它就像是神圣的，因为你基本上创建了类型空洞，然后编译器，我想是对的，是的
i saw i saw a talk about it at some facebook programming language conference that i went to a few years ago um and and yeah and so so i and i the reason I list that is that there's probably some language like that, or maybe not a language itself, but just the whole model behind machine learning programming frameworks probably deserves to be on that list in some way. Like, like, like, like I really, I really liked the definition that Sean gave last week of like machine learning is just like, you know, it's just a way to approximate a function. And the whole model of instead of, instead of writing, instead of coding logic for something, building up a neural net that you're going to train to do the right thing, instead of programming some fancy, complex system to do the right thing, I think that's sort of a novel idea. And I guess another category where, again, I don't have a language, a specific language to list and where it doesn't really exist sufficiently yet to be listed, but, um, uh, quantum compute, like programming paradigms around quantum computing are fairly different than, uh, traditional computing.
我在几年前参加的一个Facebook编程语言会议上看到过关于它的演讲，是的，所以我列出它的原因是可能存在某种类似的语言，或者也许不是语言本身，但机器学习编程框架背后的整个模型可能以某种方式值得列入该名单。就像，我真的很喜欢Sean上周给出的定义，机器学习只是近似函数的一种方式。整个模型不是编写逻辑，而是构建一个你将训练它做正确事情的神经网络，而不是编写一些花哨、复杂的系统来做正确的事情，我认为这是一种新颖的想法。我想还有另一个类别，同样，我没有一个具体的语言可以列出，而且它还没有充分存在到可以被列出的程度，但是，嗯，量子计算，围绕量子计算的编程范式与传统计算相当不同。
Yeah. The only language I know is Q sharp, which is comes out of Microsoft, um, uh, for quantum computing, but yeah, that's, it's in its infancy right now. Um, at least it, that's it's in its infancy right now um at least or either it's in its infancy or it's just outside of the stuff that i've read another term for the angelic programming thing i think the more popular term is non-deterministic programming in in connor's book sequel is a programming language but html is not yeah yeah we'll have to do a full we'll have to do a full episode on that um i feel like sequel is something that like if i really dove into i would actually fall in love with as well because sequel to me the the little that i've been exposed to it also just basically seems like an algorithm there it's basically just a bunch of joins group buys
是的。我唯一知道的语言是Q#，它来自微软，用于量子计算，但是的，它现在还处于起步阶段。嗯，至少它现在处于起步阶段，或者它要么处于起步阶段，要么只是超出了我读过的东西。关于天使式编程的另一个术语，我认为更流行的术语是非确定性编程。在Connor的书中，SQL是一种编程语言，但HTML不是。是的，我们必须专门做一期完整的节目来讨论这个。我觉得SQL如果我真的深入研究，我也会爱上它，因为对我来说，我接触到的那一点点，它基本上看起来也像是一个算法，它基本上只是一堆连接、分组。
uh selects it was highly influenced link uh in in c sharp 3 uh or like in all the later versions as well but c sharp 3.0 got link which was highly inspired by sql um there are there are sql people who have suffered at the hands of sql out there who are going to send you emails about that yeah okay maybe some people suffer but also too i think the the work behind like the the algebra and the work done behind uh relational databases and sql it's it's phenomenal like and um i think yeah that's one of the things like so the four languages in this talk that i highly recommend it's one of the things. Like, so the four languages in this talk that I highly recommend. It's one of the best talks I've ever seen.
选择，它深受C# 3中的LINQ影响，或者在所有后续版本中也是如此，但C# 3.0有了LINQ，它深受SQL启发。有一些在SQL手中受过苦的SQL人员会给你发电子邮件讨论这个问题。是的，好吧，也许有些人受过苦，但我也认为关系数据库和SQL背后的代数和工作是现象级的，我认为是的，这是我在这次演讲中强烈推荐的四种语言之一。这是我见过的最好的演讲之一。
The four languages from 40 years ago. The four languages that Scott focuses on is SQL, Prolog, ML, Smalltalk. And he actually has, oh, here's a bonus round of our game. He has a hidden language, which is going to get spoiled. So if you don't want that hidden language to be spoiled for watching the talk, pause and come back to the, listen to the last couple minutes of this episode. It was created in 1979, and he argues that it's a programming language, but like it's by all accounts, like not a programming language. But we actually, and it's, it's the predecessor, um, to, uh, a quote unquote language that we did a whole episode about earlier in this podcast. So first
40年前的四种语言。Scott关注的四种语言是SQL、Prolog、ML、Smalltalk。他实际上有一个，哦，这是我们游戏的奖励环节。他有一个隐藏的语言，这会被剧透。所以如果你不想在观看演讲时被剧透那个隐藏语言，请暂停并回来，听听这一集的最后几分钟。它创建于1979年，他认为它是一种编程语言，但从各方面来看，它不像是一种编程语言。但实际上，它是我们在这个播客早期做过一整集节目的所谓“语言”的前身。所以首先
see if you can identify what that programming language episode that we did was about. Is this the Excel episode? Yeah, it is. Yes. So what is the predecessor to Excel? I don't know. Well, did Lotus precede Excel? Technically, Lotus did, but something even preceded Lotus. And it was the killer app on, I believe, the Apple II. Oh.
看看你是否能认出我们做过的那期关于编程语言的节目是关于什么的。这是Excel那一集吗？是的，是。那么Excel的前身是什么？我不知道。好吧，Lotus是在Excel之前吗？从技术上讲，Lotus确实是，但有些东西甚至在Lotus之前。它是Apple II上的杀手级应用。哦。
Yeah, I'm not going to get this. Which is what a lot of people, it's what a lot of folks argue was actually the reason why that hardware was successful. It wasn't because of the hardware, it was because of the software. And that program was VisiCalc, which actually you probably have heard and recognized the name, but I probably also wouldn't have been able to name that off the top. And it's, yeah, it's a fantastic talk.
是的，我答不上来。很多人认为这实际上是该硬件成功的原因。不是因为硬件，而是因为软件。那个程序是VisiCalc，你可能听说过并认出这个名字，但我可能也无法脱口而出。而且，是的，这是一个精彩的演讲。
And yeah, so the point here that I was getting to is that sequel yeah he he spends quite a bit of time talking about it and how um it has persisted you know amongst so many other programming languages uh that that died and but like not only has it persisted it has absolutely like thrived um like sql is it's everywhere um data like you're not gonna you know meet a software engineer that hasn't at least heard of a database i mean think think about all the different amazon dynamo mongo like everything with a db after it um you know sql and no sql like it's it's of all the languages, you could make an argument that like SQL has been the most pervasive of all of them, quote, you know, quote unquote languages, as obviously some people wouldn't call SQL a language.
是的，所以我刚才要说的重点是SQL，是的，他花了很多时间谈论它，以及它是如何在许多其他已经消亡的编程语言中坚持下来的，而且不仅坚持下来，它还绝对蓬勃发展。SQL无处不在，数据，你不会遇到一个没听说过数据库的软件工程师，想想所有不同的Amazon Dynamo、Mongo，所有后面带DB的东西，你知道SQL和NoSQL，在所有语言中，你可以说SQL是其中最普及的，当然，有些人不会称SQL为语言。
But anyways, we should probably start wrapping up. That's where we'll end it. Thanks for listening. And we hope you have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但无论如何，我们应该开始总结了。这就是我们要结束的地方。感谢收听。希望你度过愉快的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。